>> AnnouncerTHS CNN
BREAKINGS GET RIGHT TO THE
COL'OF
OUR SE LING OW THY NALD P.
POTENTIASOANT.
>> Repor INCREDI
ICANT  SPE SEINVESTIGATION.
S" REPORTING
TRUMP'SE CHIEF
OF STAFFSTIFIED
BEFORE THE GRAND JURY, TSPECIAL
OWN AT MAA-CCORDING T TRERT
HAS TESTIFIED IN ONE OTHE
BUT HE I THET  O BOTH.
SIGNIFICANT WITNESS THAT THE
SPECIACOUNSEEAK
BUT IT COULDLYHE JANUARY
VALUABLE INFOIN
T PROB
WELL.
NTONTHS, FOLKS
AROUNDP
HAVEE NCNSME PUZZLT T EXACTLY
WHAS O MARK
MEADOWS BECAUSE THEY TOL
THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANAT
TEAM.
THEY WE UNCLEAR T
EXACTLY WAS GOING ONH HIM
AND EVEN SAID ON O THERE
WAMUTRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM MEADOWS'
LEGAL TEAM WHICHD A ESTION,
INDEED, COOPER S. IT ANKNOW, E
THAT ALL ROADS TO E FORMER
FORMER , ALL
IDNC
BEFORE INVESTIGATORS
THOUGN THMAR-A-LAGO PROBE WE DM
R IVE REPORTING INRENT WEEKS TH
TRUMP FE POSSESSION OF A CLASSIA
Y MEADOWS'
ROR
OWTO  TIMES W COMMENTING  WHETH
TESTIF MEADOWS HAS
MAMITMENT TO TEL
THE H  HAS LEGAL
SO, WOLF.
>> I WNT O WHEN
WELL-PLACES MADES
REPORT, WHAT DOES YOU ERE TH
>>S WE'V
PO PASVE
WE THE
VENAL
AND THE FACT THEY'RESES, THE REE
SAID ON AIR JUSDON'T OWMEADOWS
RIGHAT IS SUCHWITNESTALK THI CAN
FOR RT
IN THE FINAL PIKELY
LATER THIS WEEK BUT THE INVESTI
, S HAS FINALLY BEEN NFIRMED IS
BE FOR T
UNDERSTANDER THEY E, WRAPPING U
THE MO SIGNIFICANT WITNESSES
THEY WOULD SPE THIS IS
ONKELY SPOKE
THIS FHAE
ENTERING NOW BRING
Y
LET'S N FORGET THISTI
E'RECHING RIGHT
NOW.
PAULA, STAY WITH US.
I WANT TO DIG  WITH OUR D POLICT
HOW CRITICAL ITHRE?
FOR A BIG REASON, LET'S LOOK AT
THARK MEADOWS WOULD
D IN THE
HOUSE.
F OULD HE
HAD ACCESSOOK AT THEIF
INQUIRTHAT HCAPROVIDE INSIGHT A
THE PRESIDENT SAID KNEW, E
PRESIDENT EVER CON HKNEW
WHAT IPRESIDENT'S
ND
WHAT WAS HTA
SE ON
JANUY h AND OTHER,OU K
AC THERE SO PLENTY TO BE
GLEANED FROM HIM.
WITHES TO DOCUMES, IT'S SEPARATS
SIGHT INTO WHAT DID
THE PREN W
PACKED BOXES OL
DAYS OF THRATION AND
BEING SENT DOWN TO
WHAT DIDHE SAY ABOUT
T TOY DOW WAS IN
POSSESSION.
THPLENTY THAT CAN BE ASKED
OF MARK ADOWS  BOTH A
>> HE WAS DEAND POLITICAL AL
E WHIT
HOUSE, WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
ASS H OF THESE SEYS
VEIONSWANT TO QUESTI
THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTIONE
CLASFI THAT WERE
AROUND MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT'S RIGHT AN
WAS IN POSITN FIRSTHE FACT HASB
JURY AND ONE OF THE BIG
QUESI HAVE, IS
HE ACT
OTHER WOS,R QUESTIONBSTANTIVELY
HOW MANY
IN THS
ONE OF THE BIG QUESTIONS IHER O
Y CRIMINAL LIABITYN
QUESTION.T ITOUGATIONS
THE TH OTIBEFORE HE D, WHETHER
NOT HE ENTER I OF DEALH THE GOV
WHETHER OR NOTA MOTIVATION TY
HIS OWN INTERESTS
ANTHUL
HISW T
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COULD
WELL, SO THERE'S HIS OWNAL INTE
SO THE RELEVANCE TO
THOAR INVESTIGATGO BACK TOLA.ADO
TH Y ANDORTANT PIECE OF EVIDENCE
REPORTED ON SPECIFICALLY THE
AUDIO RECORDING RUMP
DISCUSSING THOSED
NTS ATO.
H A CRITICAL PIECE O
EVIDENCE FOR INVESTIGATORS.
THIS
T ONLY DE
THAT HE
IS IPO OF
CUT HELSPEARS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LIMBS ON HIS
ABY DOCUMENTS
E LEFTTE HOUSEOMMENTS ARE
UNDERMINE A LOT OFHE PUBLIC
STORY ONE OF OUR BIG QUESTIO TH
THIS ROOM WHY?
THROUGH OUR REPORT
DURING TTIMEHER
HAVING JOURNALISTS, WRIT
OWHAT HSA IN ADDITION TO HIS
.ED THAT IN THE ROOM S CRITICAL
WORKING RAPHY FOR O,, HE I
TI ITHISE SPECIFIC
SEEA
T WHAT TYPESOF RDIAVE
M BOOK,ALSO ODDLY IN MARK MEADS
MEENGH OU
REPORTINGGESTS
TH EST AT IN
INVESTIGATION.
>>IDHA A
BLOW IO FORMER PRENT
TRUMP?
IT COULD -THINK BACK TO SORT
INVESTLDMEADOWS' TRAJECTORY IN F
ER WHEN MARK MEADOWSAS
IN COOPERATIVEH
THE HOUSE SELECTEETO JANUARY 6tR
THAT AFTER HE HAD SHAR A
THE COMMITTEE.
WHE  HINVE THEPOWERFUL
THEMAKE THEIS F WHAT THEY TRUMP
LEAD-UP TO JAN A
THAT DAY, SOK MEADOWS HAS  CENTL
THROUGHOUT.
ATLLG
INVEIGMES PULLING
AT HELPING ATORS, I THOUGHT THE
OBLIGA DLAW, HE
WILL COMMITMENT
WELL, THAT SUGGESTS TO ME THAT
VALUABLE INFORMATION THAT HEN T.
I GUESFA
AL
WEE HIT HOMEE
FORMER PRESIDENTIT?
BSOLUTELY, I MEAN,
NODY CLOSER INSIDEHE
OW
LIKING ABOUT,
JANUARY 6 UP
TILL WE PRESIDENT LEFTOF THOSE .
IT'S VERY TELLING.
YES, HE STARTED TO NEGOTIATE
COOPERATE POTENTIALLY
WITH THE JAN 6th COMMITTEE,
WH CALLED FO SN'T SOMETH
PERSPECTIVE VERY DIFFERENT,
MAYB LIKKEENMIKE PENCE DID FIGO
THE GRJUTHEY LOSINN
EN.
T  H
PLAYBOOK TOOROFWHAT YOU WANT.
I LL T EN CONCERN A IA C
SOME IP ORBIT THAT HDOWS, IS MAG
AGAIN, WDON'T .O